the sign of success is the hate that you
get along the way and what you can't do
is bend the knee to their hate and fit
back into the Conformity because it's
comfortable and it's warm because every
single person who wants to do something
with their life and has done something
with their life has gone through the
exact chapter that you're going through
and it's the lonely chapter you don't
fit in with your own friends but you
don't have the outcomes yet to fit into
a new group of friends and you're going
through this and you're like is this
even worth it because you have no signs
of success but if there's anything that
you can take away from what we're saying
right now is that